so our next speaker
is a member of alpha kappa alpha
the sorority incorporated i'm not sure
the incorporated part is
um that's the same sorority as our vice
president-elect
kamala harris so everyone please welcome
kimberly
all right hello everyone and thank you
to the organizers for
um inviting me to speak to you today
uh as you may wonder what what could
possibly be the connection between
my talk and uh snoop dogg
of all things but as you can see the
topic
for my presentation today is
analyzing count data expressing data
dispersion
and as you can see uh this is done uh
through my joint partnership
at georgetown university and the census
bureau
okay um so notice snoop dogg was
counting one two three into the four
so he too can appreciate count data
all right so for context with regard to
regression analysis of course we're all
too familiar with the idea of this being
a fundamental means
by which to establish the relationship
between associated variables
for example with the census bureau one
could ask about
change in geographic units with regard
to housing growth or decline so if we're
interested in the number of new homes
in a region then obviously most
neighborhoods are stable
right so so you would not expect there
to be any new homes in that area and
that
influences the ideology of considering a
zero-inflated count model
and so with that in mind of course there
are various models that are already in
existence
and popular in use with the
zip model or the zero-inflated poisson
that underlies a poisson distribution
which assumes equidispersion in the data
which means
that the mean and variance equal if we
allow for
over dispersion i'm sorry if we allow
for over dispersion then
a zero-inflated negative binomial is
popular
more broadly for cases of where under
over dispersion i should say
implies that the variance is larger than
the mean in a data set
more broadly if we consider um over or
under dispersion
where with under dispersion the variance
is smaller than the mean
then uh one such choice to allow for
such flexibility would be
through a zero inflated generalized
poisson
distribution however it's worth noting
that this model
can express some
peculiarities and issues under certain
conditions
and so it promotes the idea of me
introducing yet another
alternative flexible model for count
data namely the zero inflated
conway maxwell poisson to offer some
background with regard to the cnp
distribution
as you can see it's it's based on a two
parameter
count model that generalizes the poisson
as a special case
the lambda parameter here serves as a
generalization of the poisson rate
parameter
and while the new parameter
serves as a dispersion parameter so
for this value nu and this
z function serves as our normalizing
constant
it's important to note that when new
equals one this simplifies to our
poisson model
where as i said the new captures the
dispersion in the data so if new is less
than one
then it captures over dispersion for new
greater than one it captures under
dispersion
uh what's nice about this distribution
is that it not only
captures the poisson distribution as a
special case but two other classical
distributions as well when new equals
zero it captures
the geometric distribution uh again
where
lambda is constrained to be less than
one now
and when nu goes to infinity it captures
the bernoulli distribution
with success probability lambda over one
plus lambda
uh when when we think about a regression
model underlying uh
this distribution uh the the
parameterization that i'll be working
with here is that which originated
by the original conway and maxwell paper
and was revived in the smelly at all
paper referenced above
however there are other
parameterizations that exist and
the interested reader can access
my wires review paper with a student of
mine bailey premium
one of the nice properties of a cmp
distribution
though is that it has an exponential
family form where i present the log
likelihood to you here
such that it has we have the ability to
recognize the joint sufficient
statistics for lambda and nu
and as you may recall from your
statistics training
uh this exponential family form allows
for now a lot of nice prop
statistical properties to exist for this
distribution
uh some other properties uh include
the ability to uh are a representation
for
the moment generating function uh and a
form for its moments where as you can
see here even just focusing on the mean
and variance
that form does is not of a closed
form because of its dependence on that z
function that infinite summation that i
presented to you earlier
as such where i present the
representations for the mean and
variance
they do have approximations that exist
uh where those approximations hold
for the cases where the data are either
over dispersed
hence mu is less than or equal to one or
lambda is sufficiently small
moving forward to think about a thinking
of a regression model
then we now have this framework where we
consider the log linear relationship
between
lambda and our covariates now what's
important to note here is that lambda
is not necessarily the mean except for
the case of the poisson model
and so more broadly what we're looking
at is a non-linear
uh functional relationship between
if you will the mean of the data and the
covariates
however in the sellers and schwelli
paper
we stand by the use of this relationship
because
it allows us to clearly recognize uh
the generalization that's attained
through from the special cases to this
broader cmp
again for the case where new equals one
we are considering the
case of a poisson model in which case uh
this log
lambda relationship is precisely the
usual
or typical relationship that we consider
for our rate parameter
as well i remind you that another
special case was the bernoulli
distribution when nu went to infinity
here the underlying logistic model then
is likewise captured
if we if we move forward to consider as
a consideration excuse me
of a zero inflated cmp then the idea now
is that we
are incorporating a generating process
that allows for excess zeros
so with the underlying c p model as our
motivation
as you can see we incorporate a third
parameter p
to consider the probability of having
extra zeros
in the data and so we can write out the
formulation
for this zero-inflated cmp model now
where now now that we're going to
broaden the scope to consider
a regression analysis for it we are
again allowing
excuse me a log linear relationship
for lambda and nu respectively um
and meanwhile a logistic model for
p so that said
it's worth noting that the zero inflated
cmp of course
captures the analogous special cases as
did the conway max
the original economy maxwell ploisson so
for nu equal to one
we recognize that we capture the zip
model or the zero inflated poisson
when new equals zero and lambda is less
than one we capture
a zero inflated geometric regression and
if you think through our special cases
remember when new equal uh went to
infinity
we captured the bernoulli so one would
imply that this
is a capturing of a zero inflated
logistic model
well what does that mean here because of
course in a logistic
the response values are either zero
zeros or ones
well all that means now is that we
maintain a logistic framework
yet we adjust in our success probability
for p of having more zeros
so with all of this in mind and uh
presuming the
log linear relationships for lambda and
nu and the logit
for the p the question now becomes how
to
estimate the corresponding coefficient
values
in those models and we we suggest doing
so through the method of maximum
likelihood
estimation and uh
where here because of the complex nature
of the underlying score equations
one has to do this numerically hence the
need for
r and so we can perform optimization
procedures such as the non-linear
the bounded non-linear minimization or
the direct nonlinear minimization or
simply a general optimization form
where in all of these cases it's
recognized that the function of interest
is to be minimized
and hence the function that one would
supply would actually be the negated
log likelihood form of the function of
interest
and with this optimization the advised
starting parameters
or starting values would be those values
with which
say we consider under a poisson model so
be it either regular poisson regression
or the zero inflated
uh analog depending on your model of
interest
and so with those starting values in
place then
uh the optimization procedure can can
occur and we can obtain our estimates
and meanwhile we can maintain the form
of the underlying hessian
to establish our fisher information
matrix and thus
obtain our standard errors
next uh with all of this in mind a
popular question that usually arises is
how to
uh uh how to perform a test
to assess for the existence of potential
significant dispersion in the data
and so a natural approach here would be
to consider a likelihood ratio test
since much of the information is already
contained under the hood if you will
within our regression object
and of course we remember that under the
proper regularity conditions
the transformed likelihood ratio test
statistic
has a chi-squared distribution with one
degree of freedom
uh alternative we can perform parametric
bootstrapping
uh as a means by which to conduct our
test as
well meanwhile it's also worth noting
if one is interested in one of the other
special cases
say the geometric or the bernoulli just
recognize that since new is in the
in the boundary in those conditions we
have to
consider a chi-squared mixture for those
for those instances
so with all of this in mind uh my
package compass on reg
is available on crayon and can handle
everything that's been discussed here
so it can fit the
excuse me the cmp or its zero inflated
analog
model to data
and it can provide one with estimates uh
perform hypothesis testing
or model diagnostics it can handle
constant or variable dispersion
and to illustrate uh this model
uh and our package excuse me i provide
us with the following illustration with
regard to
maternal health and mortality data
and so here we are considering an
example
where we are we have collected data
across
various provinces in the dominican
republic
and we're interested in understanding um
various aspects about maternal health
and birth outcomes and so as you can see
here
we pull the data from online uh
regarding information such as the number
of deaths
across these different provinces and
um variables such as the number of beds
uh the number of vaginal or c-section
births respectively
the number of abortions etc
and so the idea is to consider an
association between the number of deaths
that have occurred in each of the
provinces versus some
measure regarding these various um
explanatory variables
okay and of course we're going to do
this using uh oh
since since we're assuming uh or find in
the data that
that there don't seem to present any
excess zeros in this data set
we simply went with the basic cmp
regression for illustration
all right so what we see here is
the call glm.cmp is the functional call
to perform a cmp regression where
the usual formula is as one would always
expect where we have the response tilde
the explanatory variable
of interest and here we're just running
a simple illustrates
a simple regression uh to associate the
number of deaths with the number of beds
and so uh when we run a summary of the
model output
you get what you would expect namely
and i should be clear the output is
stretched over this
and the next slide where what's
initially presented
is the of course the natural coefficient
table
that exists for uh the coefficients
associated with
lambda and that associated with nu
here and so as you'd expect we have the
corresponding
uh estimates standard errors z values
and p values
in particular i focus your attention on
that p value for
the if you will the gamma term that
associates with nu
we notice that it's statistically
significant here
and uh that is uh reiterated
in the output directing us with regard
to new so we have a direct
estimate for the constant dispersion new
notice it appears to be statistically
significantly less than one
in fact it's um on the closer end
to zero here and we provide the
corresponding standard error
uh more output as you see which is
presented
includes the sample size uh various
information criteria and convergence
information
focusing our attention on the aic and
bic
we'll touch on this later but it's
important to note that because the data
set was over dispersed
um it one of the reasons that this can
happen
uh here i'm just pointing out that the
optimization did in fact converge one of
the reasons for
over dispersion is that the model may
not be complete enough in other words we
should consider more variables in our
model doing that here
we find that the coefficient table
now presents uh an output where
the gamma parameter is not statistically
significantly different from zero
and what this implies is that the value
for new is not statistically
significantly different from one
what does this mean for us here that
under this
fuller model we have something that can
can be achieved apparently with poisson
regression
and that is uh more settling when we
look at the information criteria
and recognize that the aic and bic
values have now been reduced which is
what we would hope for a more optimal
or preferential model and so with this
information in place we can now make the
informed decision
to consider oh sorry for completeness
i'm noting that the
optimization did in fact converge again
but now for completeness and more uh
precision
in our estimation we can now go to
the usual glm and conduct our poisson
regression
accordingly and so now when we run it
what we're obtaining is more information
with regard to the
the usual suspects we have our
coefficient table we can look at
statistical significance
we have more refined measures of the
estimates in place
here for understanding and with that
said
because i have now reduced my model
consideration to the poisson
i have reduced the associated aic
accordingly because i've removed the
extra dispersion parameter
so while this is an illustration um and
the analysis
is deserving of more study one of the
points of note here
uh that came came of it was the question
of potential
incorporation of offsets into the model
and the current form of the compos on
reg does not allow for that
and so this is uh ongoing work that's in
place now to try and incorporate offsets
so in conclusion i hope you've learned
that the
zi cmp serves as a powerful regression
uh if not for uh explanation but also
for
generalization should you have over
under disbursed data particularly under
dispersed data
it contains uh common regressions and
the compost on reg package is a very
helpful tool
for addressing this matter uh more work
that has since been done with regard to
regression further expands to what i
call a zero-inflated
sum of cmps which contains a
zero-inflated binomial
poisson and negative binomial is special
cases
the cmp doesn't my work in the cmp does
not stop here
it spreads onward to work in control
charts distribution theory
etc as you can see here a wide array of
methodological
developments and so in closing and
recognizing the time
i just want to thank uh the co-authors
or collaborators that were involved
with various aspects of the projects
that led to this talk today
thank you for your time thank you
and i noticed in the chat it is nice
seeing someone pronounce poison
correctly which i still can't do
despite asme helping me on twitter thank
you for pronouncing that correctly
um because that that was awesome and
like i said to i say i was saying
earlier
that's my favorite distribution so i
love seeing this talk really spoke to me
a lot
and there's a nice like got a lot of
old-fashioned statistics in there
you know the census bureau i think as a
conference full of data people we can
all say how much we love and respect the
census bureau and
the great things they offer to this
country for over 200 years now
giving us this not just the desti annual
census but the rolling acs
is so valuable as statisticians um i
think we should all
you know be very thankful and go thank
kimberly for
for uh not just kimberly but the whole
census bureau for this but everyone
tagged kimberly on twitter
because that was awesome all right
so now we come